a Ginny Thomas the wife of Supreme Court
Justice Clarence Thomas now says that
she regrets all of those texts about the
2020 election we're going to look at her
latest claims but I think it's important
to remind you
Ginny Thomas really is like Q Anon level
out of her mind I want to remind you of
a text message that Ginny Thomas again
remember the wife of Supreme Court
Justice Clarence Thomas who had issues
come before him related to the 2020
election Jenny Thomas texted Mark
Meadows once quote
Biden crime family and ballot fraud
co-conspirators elected officials
bureaucrats social media censorship
managers fake stream media reporters are
being arrested and detained for ballot
fraud right now and over the coming days
and will be living in barges off of
Guantanamo Bay to face military
tribunals first edition folks that's q
and on level insane and with with this
barges off of gitmo thing I always go
back to
if they're on a barge why does it have
to be off the coast of gitmo and if it's
near gitmo why does it have to be on a
barge why wouldn't they just be there of
course remember this wasn't happening
factually it wasn't happening there were
no Biden crime family co-conspirators
being arrested uh and detained they
didn't put him on a barge they didn't
put him on a cruise ship they didn't put
him on a dinghy
I mean maybe incidentally some of them
were on boats at some point in time this
quite literally didn't happen this is
just one example of how Bonkers this
woman is okay
she now says she regrets it new report
Yahoo news just a couple days before New
Year's
Jenny Thomas the conservative activist
and wife of Supreme Court Justice
Clarence Thomas told the January 6
committee she regretted the text
messages and emails she sent in the
aftermath of the 2020 election to Mark
Meadows
Trump's former Trump's then Chief of
Staff according to a new newly released
transcript of her September interview
with the committee
Thomas said she regretted the fact that
the messages became public
now that's very different I apologize
because what I said was wrong I
apologize if anyone was offended well
those are two very different things
Thomas told Congressional investigators
quote I don't know how many of you would
want your texts to become public on the
front page of the Washington Post
certainly I didn't want my emotional
texts to a friend released and made
available
remember that in the messages Ginny
Thomas urged Meadows to make sure Trump
did not concede to Biden and parroted
many of the falsehoods and conspiracy
theories that were spreading among the
more Fringe claims pushed by Thomas was
the baseless theory among Q Anon that
Trump watermarked mail-in ballots to
track fraud and a claim circulated on
right-wing websites that in Thomas is
retelling as I told you the Biden crime
family is being sent to barges off the
coast of gitmo this is truly cuckoo for
Cocoa Puffs and my concern is people are
allowed to be crazy
that's not new people are allowed to be
unhinged conspiracy theorists we have
tens of millions of them in the United
States many of them voted for Trump in
2020. the issue is the proximity to
Clarence Thomas who was involved in
adjudicating
elements related to that election and I
guess we're meant to believe that Ginny
Thomas and Clarence Thomas never talked
about this she believed Biden crime
family conspirators were on barges but
she just never mentions it to Clarence
Thomas
that is very difficult to believe and so
of course the concern is really Clarence
Thomas and what is one of the most
radical right Supreme Courts and
arguably one of the most partisan
Supreme Courts oh I know they're
nonpartisan they simply look at the law
and they relate that to the facts and
they render a completely unbiased
political opinion a legal opinion
obviously we know that doesn't that's
not the case uh that's really the
concern and that appears to be beyond
the purview of what was the January 6
committee which remember is done because
a new Congress is sworn in today
scary that she's that nuts but also
scary that she is that close to one of
the most powerful nine justices in the
United States
who heard cases related to that very
election will have more on these text
messages on our Instagram which you can
find at davidpakman show depressing
stuff I will tell you